hi everybody welcome to episode 7 I
think it's episode 7 probably and
today's show we're kind of doing a
subject very close to our own hearts yes
and I actually wrote a book about this
but it's actually Tom's experience it's
called the mammoth mountain poltergeist
yeah that was Jenny's first book on
paranormal nonfiction yeah and this was
kind of this is kind of interesting how
this came about for those of you know
I'm primarily a horror writer have been
for many years and hadn't really thought
about writing anything in the paranormal
line but then probably not too long
after me and you got together and you
told me about this experience you had in
1982 yeah wasn't just me it was my me my
hand my uncle and my cousin yeah it was
my extended family and he kind of told
me all the details and I talked to his
aunt and uncle about it you know they
had also seen it and even though at that
point I was a complete and total like
paranormal skeptic of all things prayer
I just thought it was all [ __ ] but I
found the story so interesting and so
creepy that I was like man we should we
should do a book about that I think that
would be good cuz it was just such a
cool story and you don't really see a
lot of you don't really see like a lot
of nonfiction paranormal ones books that
aren't like bullshitty or an arm like
exaggerated because that was something I
didn't really want to do yeah you didn't
we didn't want to do the Hollywood touch
and turn it into something like what was
that one that they did what's the one
they made the movie about Amityville
Horror
yeah which wasn't even really based on a
real case we didn't want anything like
that
I Jenny asked me if she could do the
book and I said yeah but let's do it as
a paranormal nonfiction and I wanted to
just be a reconstruction of what
happened you know there's no real what
were we didn't Hollywood eyes it at all
yeah I mean basically we just kept it to
what you guys saw right and and I have
to say that you know I first heard the
story from you obviously but I also
called your aunt and uncle in California
who had also been there and I talked to
them and they without like independently
of you right they told me the same see
yeah we saw this and this and this so
you know we've all went through it
together and right and it was something
else that it changed my life I mean you
know I kind of count myself lucky to
have experienced what people would call
the paranormal because otherwise I would
have never believed it but this is just
a straight account of what happened yeah
and it was just what happened it was
weird and it was undeniable and I'm kind
of getting ahead of myself it started at
this ski lodge in Mammoth Mountain but
it continued at my aunt's house and it
lasted for about two weeks and well I
don't want to I don't want to spoil I
don't want to spoil everything about it
but we'll just kind of go into some of
the highlights I mean you know right
that is if you like the paranormal and
you like poltergeist and this is
poltergeist not in a sense of ghosts
which there's a difference and we can
get into that later it did not usually
when someone says a haunting that what
they're describing is something that
involved ghosts you know spirits of the
dead there's usually apparitions but
very rarely is anything moving
this is poltergeist what we saw was
poltergeist which was objects moving but
no manifestations of any humanoid forms
or thing like that it was classic
poltergeist which I don't know when
poltergeist accounts go way back
yeah that's true they do yeah they're
almost as old as ghosts ghosts again but
there is a difference between the two
which we get into that in the book yeah
so I
proceed the well another thing is is
that we have photographs of the place
yeah today you know what it looks like
today it is for sale we're not going to
tell you give you the address of course
we don't want you bothering these people
huh yeah I changed it in the book too so
if you think you're gonna read the book
and be like I want to find that place
yeah I'd changed the name of the Roger
changed the number of what thing cuz you
know only a few pair of psychologists
that we dealt with know the actual
address you know it's of course is in
it's in Mammoth Lakes it's at Mammoth
Mountain California yeah but there's a
lot of ski lodges up there yeah and they
a lot of them look alike and honestly I
mean really and what and we'll kind of
get into this too but I did the lower
no it doesn't matter in this case
because in this particular case it
didn't have anything to do with that
particular place I mean you guys didn't
live there you were not there on
vacation and when you left it followed
it's followed or the effect followed us
yeah that's what you know so you know so
I don't know it's not a location-based
phenomena yeah like so like a haunting
would ready to have been but it's I mean
I'm sure that won't dismayed people from
when you're trying to fight it anyway
but I'm telling you that the location
was not relevant no it's only relative
to the story when you read the book yeah
yeah and we have photographs of it that
we took from the time that it happened
and they're in the book yeah but these
are new photographs of the place because
it's up for sale and it's been you know
it's been remodeled memory model doesn't
look exactly the same as another 1982 no
doesn't look like but you can you can
tell looks like they they relocated a
few doors yeah but this is the place
what would be a good way to start
telling about man well anyway well you
don't want you know one thing we have to
say is that the reason why we're doing
this show is because the audio book the
audio version of this book is going up
for sale yet shortly right the the print
version and the eBook version are
already up I mean they came out last
year in 2015
but we recently did well I recently did
an
book version of it that will be a per
sale in about a week or so yeah it's
just a few days from when this podcast
goes up and it was it's a it sold very
well it's got good reviews and I think
we're think it's averaging like four and
a half stars out of five yeah and and it
led to working with Steve Mara and
running some other paranormal books
later on because because he read it
mehran enjoyed it when we released this
book it caught the attention of some
parasite well one parapsychologist in
particular that asked Jenny to write a
couple of books on cases that he was
involved in yeah and those are also for
sale but there's he's got a third one
that he wants to do not Stockport the
stock board that was yeah that was
actually one case gonna delve into that
that'll be coming soon so that you can
just consider this kind of like some
bonus for our fans that have bought yeah
math Mountain poltergeist we today we
can show you what it looks like now yeah
what it looks like today you can like
you know like I said you can talk a
little bit about your experiences maybe
what happened in each room what happened
each for me what that kind of stuff cuz
you know it's one thing reading it but
then it's one thing hearing the person
that's talking of it you know and at the
time that it happened we only had a
Polaroid camera with what did that carry
15 15 shots back in the day I think the
Polaroid that little pack didn't know it
only had seven was it only seven for
some reason I want to say it was seven
yeah and we only have some weird number
so we weren't able to take a whole lot
of pictures but yeah enters that
survived over the years the really cool
ones there in the book yeah certain
things that it did okay
well let's uh let's shown what it looks
like okay now for those of you listening
the audio podcast sorry you can't see
this but when I put up it yeah when I
put up the YouTube video to I'm going to
you could look at it yeah I'm gonna put
a link in actually in the audio podcast
I'll put a link in the description so
you can go and see some of the pictures
although I have to say this pictures
does have the actual address on it if it
won't on the photos okay we copy those
photos they won't get the address okay
alright now what you're looking at is
the
is the front of the chateau alright and
this is how I remembered it when I was
there I think I think even the colors
are the same well now I now you guys
took a picture of the outside of it from
from the car because I put that in the
book now I was hard to tell us it was
kind of far away I think it was blue was
it um but me I don't know it was hard to
tell cuz like I said it was snowing and
kind of far away it's actually kind of
an olive green now right it was blue but
that's that's just kind of I really you
know it gives me that impression of
looking at it again yeah and the snow
and everything now if you see the top
window there that is the window that I
just that I talked about in the book
when we were in the parking lot in front
of this the parking lots right there in
front of that door you can't see him cuz
they're covered in snow but that's the
place where you could park yeah we
looked up there and saw that those
shades had been opened and that the
lights were on
that's the window that I'm talking about
okay why not now that front door right
there that's the front door I ran out of
after it moved the lamp and when you go
into that front door the fur immediately
on your right is an entrance into
another room and that was the the room
that I spent the first night in when I
heard the telephone receiver pick up
okay and heard something dragged itself
across the floor and and you only slept
in there that one night so yeah you
should probably talk about that like
talk about going up there and talk about
well I'll talk about that when I show
you want to show you the picture of the
room okay but that's that's it and it
let's go on to the next photograph okay
okay this is upstairs and this is the
upstairs living room and behind that
couch is that window that I that you
just saw from that coming outside so
that's the top floor we spent most of
the time in there on a high to bed yeah
but too high to bed at this angle would
have been kind of behind you and up
against the wall though
those couches weren't there and off to
the right you see that little planner
that's the that's where the stair case
comes up now that window right there is
where the word go was scrawled in wax
from the twist tie yeah it was that
window right there that you see okay now
off to your left that's like a sliding
glass door that goes on a little patio
but we didn't go out on it the whole
time we were there because at that time
it was stacked full of firewood okay and
it was snow in there but that that's
that same little fireplace think it's
exactly the same Oh interesting
yeah that was there they haven't moved
that oh that's the exact same original
one and the carpets new I think the
carpet
oh yeah originally it was like a 70s
shag yeah it was terrible
but that's about it for that photo
what's the next one the next one is okay
this is that same upstairs same room but
it's a different angle right that that
is the sliding glass door or go back
that's the sliding glass door that goes
goes out to the to the patio that had
the firewood stacked on it
now see with a little chair is that's
where the height of bed was okay and
that when it was folded up that's where
I was sleeping when the front door chain
got locked off got knocked off okay
remember by the yeah which that that's
that's in the book but that's where I
was sleeping when I heard that front
door lock go BAM yeah torn off now
behind that wall is that master bedroom
that's where Louis and red were sleeping
okay and that's where red came from when
he ran out and said what was that okay
so yeah this this angle is taken from
right when you come up the stairs okay
now if you were to pan right you'd see
the kitchen in the dining room and the
hallway that went down the master
bedroom in the bathroom that's it and
see a little skylight boy that brings
back memories
that gives me chills okay really yeah it
does now in that back corner you used to
be hanging from the ceiling was a around
lamp on a chain you know like those
tacky yeah you yeah you guys have a
picture of that that was taken at the
time I used to hang that was hanging
right there in that corner from the
ceiling yeah that's the next one yeah
see the next one okay yeah here's here's
where this is right near that patio door
this is this is a shot into that room in
the dining room where you see it now is
where it was back then but up against
that wall there was something kind of
like like shallow bookshelves or that's
what I think they were think of a book
shelves up against there but I don't
remember there being any books in them I
think there were little decorations I
think we have pictures of those in the
book and see the counter that countertop
was there although it's a different
countertop back in those days it was
like tiles yeah three or four or four by
four inch little tiles yeah and that's
where Louis saw the Glasgow Grove moving
across I didn't I didn't see that she
saw it she saw that I didn't see it and
then the kitchen is remodeled it's a lot
nicer than it used to be i I think they
were just wood brown wood cabinets and
that's a different stove but if you if
you see that light on that nights are on
that end table right there is the
hallway that goes back towards the the
master bedroom in the bathroom okay that
was the hallway I was walking down or
that was the hallway that red was
walking down when he looked right and
saw the rocking chair rocking around
flying okay I was at the other end of it
okay let's go to the next picture yeah
that's it that's the dining room its
remodeled but that's just another angle
of it on the next one you hatching yeah
it's definitely see that's a single
piece of marble counter that's totally
remodeled yeah the the the refrigerator
has been moved used to be the
refrigerator was right next to the so
they changed
I mean not much stuff happened in the
kitchen no no God Li
I remember that it turned the the oven
knobs on yeah a couple of times but then
it only did it a few times yeah it
seemed like most the activity was
centered in other rooms I have a feeling
I have a feeling that that sinks been
slightly relocated but not much happened
in there yeah and we didn't cook we
weren't you know we were eating fast
food I think yeah okay what's the next
one that is the master bedroom you see
the doorway there in the corner going on
to the into the bathroom that wasn't
there in my day that there was no door
there okay the door was on the other
side of that wall and and you could only
get to it by going down the hallway so
they remodeled that that way people in
the master bedroom could just get to the
bathroom without having down yeah that
makes more sense now I don't know if
there is a second door there at the end
of the hallway probably there's probably
two doors right there but that is
exactly where the bed was when we were
there when the sheets or when the
comforter was pulled off of the bed in
the end the pillows went flying up and
went over my aunt uncle's head yeah and
it if you're looking at if you're
looking at it from this angle that's
what they would have basically would
have seen but the but the pillows would
have come up went right over their heads
and behind them was a closet but that
closet had a top to it it didn't extend
all the way up to the ceiling because it
kind of has a vaulted ceiling that was
kind of slanted oh yeah diagonal so
there was kind of like a storage space
above the closet and that's where that's
where they went that's where the witch
cult see the pillows went and on the
right there is the drapes it's not the
exact same drapes that it used to be
those that's where the drapes flew open
at time and that's also the same drapes
where I put the folded up hand towel
vanished and with my back pocket right
which that's a great story and that
really freaked us out and really from
the angle that this is taking would have
been right where the rocking chair was
that was rocking back
fourth it was right in that position and
that we have a picture that rock and
chair in the book yeah but it's all new
furniture but that's pretty much the
location that's where it was it's a lot
smaller than I pictured it it's a lot
smaller than I remembered it but you
know yeah I mean I don't know when you
were telling me about it I pictured a
much bigger room yeah because it seemed
like the master bedroom I mean that was
like the center of a lot of a lot of the
stuff that happened happened in there
yeah you know I was 13 so it was smaller
than I am now but I remembered it being
bigger yeah but yeah looking at it go
yeah I guess it wasn't yes it's just an
average size room yeah it brings back
memories even though it looks different
I know what happened in that place yeah
okay it's going on the next one that's
the bathroom okay that's where you see
that window yeah used to be on either
side of those were some like like drapes
but they were lightweight like you'd see
in a in a bathroom they were kind of
like a little doily material oh yeah
that's where I saw what looked like hand
prints wiped like somebody had wiped the
greasy hands on that on the character
does a little curtains next to that and
that that bathroom back there that's
where Louis was showering and when she
got out she saw that the toilet paper
had been taken off of the roll or you
know to been strewn you know how can you
pull a sheet of toilet paper yeah it was
like a sheet of toilet paper big long
sheet of it was pulled off of the roll
and it got wrapped around the handle to
the outside of the shower door yeah she
found it like that while she was
showering and the door was closed
that inner door was closed and that
happened nope nobody opened it holy [ __ ]
yeah she said that really scared her
yeah cuz it just happened while she was
taking a shower and then that glass that
sliding glass doors glass yeah and no
one went in there and you couldn't do it
to yourself because the door was shut
you can reach over there and pull that
toilet paper and then pull yeah pull it
and wrap it around there that was spooky
I didn't see that of course she just
called out to read when she was coming
out and I he saw
and I went I went over there said what
happened and red said oh man look at
looking into the toilet paper
you know Lois is wrapped in a towel wow
that's pretty freaky yeah that one
really honestly I don't I don't remember
cuz I don't think I put that in the book
because I don't remember her telling me
that at the time there was so much stuff
that's the Navy happens that we can't
even remember I'm like yeah inevitably
and I think and I think like you seeing
was yes in the book that there was so
much stuff that happened that we can't
remember at all it's just a constant
barrage of it yeah something would move
once every 15 minutes and yet sometimes
a bunch of stuff would move in a little
short period of time yeah but there's
more detail in the book but looking at
these old photos kind of brings back
memories of so that's what I mean that
might be jogging something looser I
don't remember now I remember her
telling me that she was in the shower
once and she came out and like there
were these like washcloths or towels
like folded in weird places they're like
hung over the knobs and stuff and there
had been in there and like they hadn't
been there before
but I don't remember her telling me that
the toilet paper wrapped it so around
the market I remember that that's crazy
yeah wouldn't you it was it was it did
the same kind of things over and over
and over again and it was all
nonsensical there was you know no
attempt at communication which we kind
of get into that in the book when that
kind of fits a pattern of classic
poltergeist activity yeah it's kind of
like meaningless meaningless random [ __ ]
there's no attempt to communicate not
really not really except for that one
word at room yeah but that's not true
that's like signaling and teasing it's
no extended conversations nothing like
that yeah okay this room is the room the
room that I spent the night in them for
the very first night it's just that it's
been changed they put bunk beds in it
okay where you see the TV and that one
buck bed right there
that would have been the head of the bed
was up against that that I slept in and
all in that corner over there is where
the
I'd stand would have been where the
telephone was sitting this shot is taken
from the corner right next to this right
next to the sliding doors to the the
dresser where I heard the coat hangers
rattle but that's that's where I spent
the first night that that room is uh
pretty weird I don't reckon you know of
course the decor is totally different
none of that was in there and I think
the walls were just white but I just
remember the angles that's the only
place where that could be yeah
it's that first first room on the right
on the ground floor so that's where I've
been spent the first night that's when I
realized that something was wrong which
I get into in the book let's go on to
the next one yeah it's from another
angle
okay uh that window is what I would have
been facing when I was laying in bed
basically this is right from the doorway
when you walk in and to your right you
would if you'd pan over a little bit
you'd see where the closet was in those
days it was just like a long low dresser
like one of those old four drawer
dressers was up against that window but
nothing real remarkable just it's gone
to the next one that's one of the battle
that's one of the downstairs bathrooms
and I think there were two of them
side-by-side but other than that I don't
remember much about that we can go to
the next one nothing really happened in
there this is that last room on the
right where Wesley was sleeping on the
first night
and I think he slept there on the second
third night too now yeah because and I
kind of mentioned that in the book too
but Wesley your cousin he did not seem
particularly bothered by her Geist
activity he wasn't really aware what was
going on because with things would
happen so fast
you know his spatial awareness you know
he was slightly autistic his spatial
awareness wasn't like what everybody
else's was like it's normal for us to
know when someone walks
to a rumor moves an object yeah but not
to a deaf and autistic person people
could come in behind him and move
something then walk out and he'd never
know and so he grew up finding objects
moved right oh yeah I gotcha yeah
so if he'd find objects move running
just assume that we did it right and we
would try to explain to him what was
going on and he was just kind of
incredulous although he did seem creeped
out in that house I think it was some of
it was denial and later I have to say um
he would deny it later on yes he did he
denied he said to me Maya yeah but um
when he found out that I was writing a
book about it
then he wanted to talk about then he
wanted to talk about it and he did write
me a short story a short thing about a
couple of things that he had seen yeah
said he didn't like to talk about it
right he thought it had something with
black magic and witchcraft type of a
deal oh really that's what he told me
one time he thought there was some
sorcerer that lived there but you know
he's got an imagination you know he's
he's Daphnis and he's quite religious
and but there's no evidence of that
there was no evidence he a sorcerer were
ever lived there this is what he thought
yeah it was creepy and the drafting
table in the other room that kind of he
didn't like that he thought that was
weird thought they had something do
witchcraft and that drafting table would
have been on the other side of that wall
up where the head of that bed is it's an
actus in the room because there were
three bedrooms on the ground floor right
yeah and then the master bedroom is on
the other side of that wall is the room
where we've worked first confronted us
by moving there yeah let's see if they
have a picture they have a picture that
this is the same room that's that same
room yeah that's the room that Wes was
in of course it looks totally different
now yeah that's another one of the
bathrooms okay that that's probably
that's the room yeah that's the room
where the where the lamp moved now it
had a bunk bed back in those days also
but it's not the same one the original
bunk bed looked like was made of huge
tree trunks and it was very heavy and it
was in that corner yeah but it wasn't
along that side of the wall was on the
other wall up against that window okay
that's where it was and then at the I
guess you could say
head of it at the head of that bed was
that little dresser with a with a with a
lamp on it almost where that dresser
with the lamp it on is that now it's
just that you know if you just slide
that over about another four feet that's
that's where the other dresser was okay
you know say I'm talked about yeah and
then if you were to keep going panning
right up against that wall was that
drafting table now if you were to pan
left there was along that wall there
you'll eventually hit another closet in
that wall that's how I can explain it
and that's where it tried to put the
lamp inside that closet and fasted to
tell the lamp story it's all the lamp
story because that the lamp story was
like the first definitive thing because
you guys had been experiencing weird
[ __ ] since you got there kind of like a
little things like creepy things creepy
feelings yeah but that was the first
thing that everyone saw at one time man
all right what happened with the lamp we
all went out to the ski slopes but my
uncle red and I we went we actually
didn't didn't want to ski we didn't want
to learn how to ski we didn't care about
it and I was kind of wigged out from
some stuff that it happened the night
before which I get into in the book and
I can't remember exactly we were in the
car
Michael red was like let's let's drive
around for a little bit well that Louis
ski yeah so my uncle and I are driving
around and I said a red do you believe
in haunted houses and he's like well we
know why you asking me this you know
make a long story short he's like okay
we'll go back and check it out so we go
back to the to the Chateau and when we
get there we find all these folded hand
towels at the foot of the bed some of
them our own backs of doors and we were
just missed the fiber like is this room
service or something but it was just
where the hand towels were and how they
were folded is not the way a maid would
do it well they did they left they left
them like hanging on doorknob doorknobs
the back of doorknobs
the backs of chairs and thing yeah that
like just in weird places well in this
room you're looking at now there was a
drafting table and the drafting table
had a stool on it and the stool had a
back and on the back on the back rest of
that stool was a hand towel folded over
it and it was folded over in one-thirds
you know you fold the three times and
then you put it over the back and my
uncle just points it and he's going what
is this you know who does this I said I
don't know
well my uncle then grabbed that that
stool and pushed it in cuz the head was
pulled out a bit he pushed it in and he
says okay let's get out of here and we
go back to get Louis and my uncle's like
hey don't tell Louis about this she'll
chill you know freaked out and we list
not let's not panic or anything [ __ ] you
know Bobo it says okay so we pick up
Louis and the first thing you do I'm 13
I start blabbing about the ghosts you
know I let the cat right out of the bag
so we Louis is like yeah that's weird I
that place is kind of creepy you know
let's go check it out you know so when
we get back we take her right to that
room right there and show her that hand
towel that was on the back of that stool
and she's gone yeah that's weird you
know I said read look at that chair man
that's pulled back out again you pushed
that in and he said yeah yeah I did push
that end in and I said yeah I remember
you pushing that thing in and it's
pulled out a good eight inches nine
inches now and I was like yeah that's
weird man somebody must be in here so we
all start backing out of that room and
read shuts it shuts the door to that
room and we walk a few steps down that
hallway and Rivlin hold on wait a minute
let's go back and memorize that you know
I forgot to tell it Louis is common I
always do this I've always made a
comment while we were in that room she
goes boy that is an ugly lamp yeah and
then we left we get down the hallway red
goes little hold on let's go back and
check this room let's go memorize that
room again just just in case something
moves so he goes and opens the door and
I heard everybody gasp and I look to see
what they're looking at and the lamps
gone it was gone
and we had just shut that door three
seconds ago
well I screamed and ran out the hallway
and ran out that front door and huff and
puff for a little bit tried to catch my
breath and I'm looking back down the
hallway and I just see him in there you
know plain as day talking to each other
looking inside that room and I said well
I guess there's no danger I ran back in
to look at the aftermath again and
they're just sitting there in the
doorway marveling because the lamp is
gone and it's almost in that closet and
the cord is trailing across the floor in
the direction of where the lamp used to
be because that's where the plug was so
it's like it grabbed it picked it up
trying to run with it about a good 10 15
feet with the with with the cord
trailing behind it and it was absolutely
silent and it was fast it was fast yeah
you said you had walked maybe a couple
tables down the hall and there was only
one doorway in and out of that room
and I mean if someone was in there you
would have heard them moving it oh yeah
you couldn't walk around with that yeah
well my uncle goes no no way no way
there's got to be somebody in here so he
checks that back window that window you
see right there and it was plastic hated
from the inside and all the plastic was
still intact there's no other doors in
or out of there
so then he starts getting on his hands
and knees and starts pulling up the
carpet around where it meets the walls
looking to see if there's a hidden door
a trap door yeah cuz he's going is there
something underneath this house is there
a basement was there a way to get up
here there's nothing just it was weird
because we have to say that for a long
time being read was a very you know a
pretty practical guy I guess yeah you
don't want to accept there's something
invisible in the house right so for a
long time he was trying to come his wall
there's somebody in here yeah like
somebody's sneaking around yeah and I
must admit I did feel a presence you
know it felt like something bearing down
on you but no human presence I mean
there wasn't there wasn't a human takes
up room they take up space yeah when
they walk they make noise they have to
have a place to hide or to go to and
this is happening
so there's no places to hide no places
to and you guys were in there almost
constantly for the entire week I mean
you didn't really leave that much so
it's like no I would have seen somebody
no it was quite an ordeal yes it around
and well as soon as I saw the lamp move
you know that was my proof that's all I
needed to see I knew that at the time I
was saying it's a ghost yeah now as time
went on I I no longer believed it was a
ghost and towards the end of this whole
episode I started to think of some other
than a ghost we get into that into in
the book and what was was a poltergeist
and in the book we use a lot of stuff
that came from other studies to pair of
psychology's over that over the decades
to explain what a poltergeist is and a
poltergeist is our spk recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis so it's
usually subconscious psychokinesis which
we can get into that later but anyway it
was a very very impressive phenomenon
very scary okay let's go on to the next
photo okay well actually what we're
right at 34 minutes so let's pause for a
break well quit real quick and then
we'll come back and pick it back up okay
so good I would like to take a second
and thank subculture corsets in clothing
for sponsoring project I radio and my
show while listening to my podcast
please take a second and visit their
website at www.att.com/biz gothic
steampunk and pinup clothing shoes and
accessories again their website is
subculture corsets calm or if you're in
the Jacksonville Florida area stop by
their store in The Avenues Mall and if
you like to save money use the discount
code 13 o'clock when checking out and
save 10% off your entire order by the
way if you're a curvy girl subculture do
not forget about you they carry size 4
to 4 X and guys they have men's clothing
and shoes as well so go shop at
subculture corsets calm now and use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount ok and yeah I know it's like I
always like to talk because it's really
interesting and I think people draw
think it's interesting I
think it's interesting but you do kind
of get all ya get why I'm talking about
this okay this is that same this is that
same room
where that television is that's where
that drafting table was where that lamp
is right now that's about where that
lamp was where the ugly lamp was right
but it didn't look like it wasn't that
same lap it was uglier the one in this
picture is pretty ugly probably was from
the 70s it was old then yeah okay what's
the next photograph yeah we're back up
in the UH in the mainland yeah that's
just the mainland
yeah in the book we have a go back to
that in the book we have a we have a
photograph of that exact of that exact
room from that angle yeah I think we
have a picture of Louis right near those
stairs yeah it's like a picture of Louis
is back yeah my jacket is over that
railing right there yeah I don't know if
it's exact same railing but it is in the
exact same spot yeah and and the and the
lamp that used to hang it's a different
lamp now but the lamb that used to hang
over the staircase yeah they saw that
swing around Yeah right where you see
that chandelier yeah hanging from the
ceiling and that stair down going down
the staircase
there was one like that back then but I
think was just a round ball yeah yeah
the round ball we have a picture of that
also and Louis said that she remembered
his swinging back and forth of good what
ten feet she's due feet I don't remember
swinging that far I remember it's
swinging more like six inches each way
yeah
like swinging or going around in a
circle circle yeah kind of an orbital
yeah thing and it wasn't constant it was
just every now and then you'd see it
swinging yeah and sometimes it would be
still and you're watching you go is that
thing moving and it seemed like it would
slowly accelerate maybe it would move up
look maybe it would speed up a little
bit swinging back and forth or rotating
and then it seemed like it would stop it
was just unpredictable yeah
unpredictable and like I said we we
should we should reiterate that we call
I mean we called the case the Mammoth
Mountain poltergeist and that was where
the phenomena began yeah which was kind
of weird because it sort of started at
random I mean you guys you had never
experienced anything like that before
right yeah and you guys had never been
to this place before was like a vacation
condom had never been there and you had
never been there before but percent for
whatever reason I had a feeling on the
way out there though that something bad
was gonna happen when we driving up
there and I tell about I talk about that
in the book something did happen on the
way up the hood flew over yeah but we
discounted it it must have been some
kind of an error even even though red
went out there and checked the latch he
couldn't figure it out why I flew up but
it did fly up it scared me yeah I jumped
out of my skin when it flew up we
weren't going fast me about 50 yeah it
was snowing then we were on a mountain
road anyway yeah this is this this is
this is just where it started we were in
there for about a week and we left here
we left there and went to my aunt's
house and it it started up over there
too
and went on for about another week and
it actually did better stuff at my
aunt's house you should probably see you
should probably talk about a couple of
those I can't talk about it did better
stuff at my aunt's house is just that it
did creepier stuff at your aunt's house
yeah just but it didn't impress you as
much because we had been living with it
for a week already yeah because and and
I think both Louis and red said this is
it even at the time you know you guys
were in this vacation condo all this
crazy [ __ ] was going on yeah we didn't
know anybody there we could didn't tell
anybody we just called people on the
phone and you got and the roads were
closed to look you could for some of
your stay so it's not like you could
just worth getting the [ __ ] out of here
you can't really go anywhere we could
leave we could leave the condo yeah and
we could go get something to eat
but the road from the from the resort
down to the main down to the main roads
were closed we're closed Deandra maybe
just like the shining yeah but at my
aunt's house I did even better stuff
it's just a you know y'all we're kind of
sick of it right now not sick of it but
like ignored it all yeah your tolerance
for it goes up and then we had more
witnesses you know the neighbors would
come over and watch it this was you know
early eighties the paranormal was not a
much discussed topic then there was no
such thing
of course the Internet you didn't have
paranormal shows the closest thing you
had was like maybe in search of search F
yeah and you just didn't call the police
for [ __ ] like that you called the police
for something like that you said there's
something in the house it's moot
they just sent a damn wagon with guys
with white coats they take you out of
there you know oh yeah and you guys
think the crime you didn't tell anybody
no we kept it it was almost kind of like
a family secret for a long time that
that happened but the neighbors at
Lois's neighbors saw it yeah my mom
didn't want me talking about it
afterwards it was it was weird yeah it
was traumatic it was a traumatic
experience it was you know and when
you're being traumatized by something
that is [ __ ] invisible and something
that's not supposed to exist and
something that you have no way of
predicting what it's going to do no
because like I said now some of the
stuff that it did I mean some of the
stuff that it did at Mammoth Mountain
was kind of threatening yeah some of it
was funny yeah some of it was just kind
of random yeah anybody back off if you
had too much yeah if it looked like you
were gonna break and run or if you did
break and run it would kind of it would
kind of ease up on you would stop moving
things for a while and then the next
thing it would move would be something
small and then it would slowly build up
and build up and build up then it would
do something that impresses so baby go
get out of here you know it's in the
book because it seems like it seems like
it at Lois's house it did also like
creepier things and also like more
impressive things I'm thinking
particularly of the time when when it
was doing the thing with the socks on
your sleeping bag yeah when it tried to
talk Gordon yeah yeah it did try to talk
I couldn't understand it that that's
getting kind of that's kind of it's kind
of making me uncomfortable and thinking
about that yeah it tried to I was laying
in a cot because I was a guest at my
aunt's house so they would just put out
a cop for me and I'd put a sleeping bag
on it I was in that sleeping bag
corner room stuff had been happening all
day in the corner of the room I heard
something
sounded like water bubble you know like
the you know those drinking water big
drinking water bottles that can you have
the office we yeah and your broom yeah
that's what it sounded like it sounded
it came from the corner of the room and
I thought what that must be bubbles and
water pipes or something and then it did
it again boom
so I rose my head up and looked in that
direction
brew the bubble sound started to form
into a like a tone of a human voice but
it sounded aquatic and it was just
gibberish kind of sounded like it was
backwards and I have jumped up bolted
and ran dragging the sleeping bag behind
me left my cousin in there it didn't
bother him he was looking to hear and
hear it he was asleep anyway I by the
time this was by the time this had
happened I pretty much knew that this
thing wouldn't hurt you it could hurt
you it was strong enough to hurt you but
I knew it wouldn't because it would have
already right because the thing is at
Mammoth Mountain it had no problem at
all moving a 300-pound bunk bed yeah up
against a door so you couldn't get in
the room right get touched Louis she
yeah I'll do you know we'll talk about
that in the in the book and um trying to
think what else read had reminded me of
a lot of things that it did with the
Matchbox cars yeah we can save that for
the book but I when he when when he
brought it back up when he mentioned did
I was like yeah yeah I do remember that
happening that was weird
but some of its um so many weird things
had happened that you kind of eventually
you get to the point where you like oh
well so what you know I mean that's you
can kind of get used to anything really
yeah I was mostly just waiting for
really big stuff to happen right a
little stuff you can't ignore it
another big thing that it did is it
through that kitchen knife yeah throw a
kid I was sitting on a couch and my
was sitting on another couch my hand was
behind us and a kitchen knife flew out
of the kitchen probably six feet off the
ground it was point forward it wasn't
rolling it was just shot like it was
shot from a gun it was moving extremely
straight just in a straight line it went
over my uncle's head went out in front
of me but I didn't see it went right up
to the sliding glass door stopped then
fell straight down into the ground and
just hit me hit the ground but thud Oh
like that and that's the only part I saw
I was looking down pretty much at my
feet and I just heard don't and look
forward and there the knife was sitting
right there in front of me on its side
and I just heard my uncle react did you
see that I said yeah I hit right there
and it goes no it came from behind me it
can and then Louis oh no it came from
the kitchen because it passed her yeah
because she had just put it in there and
it flew I didn't see it fly through the
air but they did they said it went in a
straight line went right to the glass
door stopped and then was shot straight
down to the ground in a single stroke
like it just made an l-shaped pattern it
pulled its punch at the last minute
right before it got to the glass I would
have liked to have seen it but I wasn't
looking at him and it was it wasn't
looking in the right direction
I just saw hit boom which is kind of
another thing and they did bounce on a
hit boom which that which kind of
reminds me of like we'll probably get
into this in a few minutes but how it
kind of started back up again at our
house our friend Steve who did something
like that we should we should probably
go into that in the last part the show
yeah well we're at 45 minutes you
probably you probably have time to tell
that story yeah well the first thing
we're gonna do cuz I gotta take I'm
gonna take another really really short
break just 20 seconds and then we'll
come back and we'll talk about how the
mammoth mountain poltergeist returned
after 30 however many years 35 years or
whatever it is yeah it came back kind of
weak though yeah but it did come back
but it did come back and I actually got
to see it this time yeah all right so
we'll be right back
real and imaginary and I write about
them all paranormal nonfiction go to
WWJD AFRICOM or search Amazon for the
Jenny Ashford author page okay we're
back now we have some kind of theories
about maybe why this happened but you
know Tom had gone through this
experience many years ago he had like
another kind of related experience in
the early 90s yeah we talked we covered
that in the book and then since but
nothing weird had really happened up
until then now after we wrote the
mammoth mountain poltergeist and then we
were working on another book with Steve
Mara Rochdale poltergeist lizard
Rochdale fire was is Rochdale and so we
were talking about poltergeists pretty
much all the time and we you know we
went on podcast talking about yeah we've
done mammoth mountain and stuff you've
done a lot of shows on we kind of think
that maybe us talking about it so much
and like being so you know wrapped and
versed in poltergeist so immersed in
poltergeist phenomena maybe kind of made
it make a little bit of a return
appearance yeah be said you wanted to
see it and I said yeah I wish you would
have seen it you would loved it it was
awesome
yeah because I had never I think is like
I said I said at the beginning of the
show I had always been a paranormal
skeptic I'd never seen any ghosts and
ever saw a poltergeist anything I never
saw anything like that and I never
believed it I mean I believed your story
because you know you know I got a family
but I'll tell you what they saw that
[ __ ] too yeah and they saw it too and
they told me the same thing that you're
doing without any coaching from you yeah
so so so I'd always been kind of
disappointed I'm like man obviously I
would have been scared I think
but yeah you were been scared for a
while yeah
but so maybe me wanting that kind of
made it now it was nothing like to the
level that you guys described basically
now the first thing that happened I
wasn't here for that yeah what ended up
happening your mom was here yeah a
couple of her friends were here yeah and
I got into an argument and you got into
an argument with your mom and you got
mad and you went into our bedroom yeah
right and they were out in the living
room and all I heard was crash and it
was loud and I ran out there to find
them looking in the kitchen looking at
the molding that was above the kitchen
cabinets had been pulled off and the
statues of the horses were thrown on the
floor and the molding was pulled out by
the nails they weren't looking at it
when it happened their back was to it
they said it just happened in one strike
bow and I tried to rationalize it
there's a there's a vent right above
that molding where the air conditioner
blows down I just said well maybe it got
moist somehow in cold air on it somehow
it warped it I knew I was lying I mean
that's business it's not gonna pull
nails out no and that's been those
horses and that molding has been there
since we've moved in here and then five
years ago or whatever it was four years
ago then you never really looking at it
when it happens but they were in the
same room but their backs were to it
that was the first thing that happened
and the next day we had guests over it
was two days later two days later okay
two days later lmy I'm you tell from
your yeah because you see yeah because
the first thing I was at home I was at
work yeah and he just told me about it
later now we didn't really consider it
necessarily paranormal until I wasn't
totally convinced right but then a
couple days later um two of our friends
came over one evening and we were gonna
watch a movie so we have Direct TV at
the time we don't have any more Mad Max
we were gonna order Mad Max fury road
and I already seen it man I love that
movie once we'd already seen it like six
times
yeah that is such a rad movie but but
they hadn't seen it so I'm like well you
want to sell I'll watch the sevens time
I don't care so so we're trying to get
it on pay-per-view and we couldn't get
it to work and his big pain in the ass
or whatever and we were kind of getting
frustrated and Tom's mom was like well
I'll call customer service and see if
they can get him to get it started or
whatever so she's on the phone customer
service I'm sitting on one couch with
Tom our friends are sitting on the other
couch that's like perpendicular now like
in front of us there's like a glass
coffee table and there are three remote
controls on it now all of us are just
sitting there Tom's mom was on the phone
all of a sudden the DirecTV remote that
was in the middle of the coffee table
flew off the coffee table and it went
about two feet two and a half feet and
then it landed on the carpet with this
really loud thud yeah that that you know
it was laughs it didn't bounce either
it sounded like yeah it sounded like it
was full of letter like it was a brick
or something or like the floor was
magnetic and it like sucked it into it
and then like for a second everyone just
kind of sat there like stunned I was in
a daze I saw it happen but I was unmoved
like I looked I looked at our friends on
the couch and I was like did you guys
just see that and they're like looking
at me with these heat with their big
eyes like dinner plates like that and
they're like yeah they're like that just
flew off of there I'm like that's what I
thought nobody kicked the table nobody
touched the table and then immediately I
turned to Tom and asked did you do that
yeah and I was just kind of in a daze
again I looked at anyway yeah I guess so
yeah stood up I stood up after you said
that and I walked over to it towards it
and looked at and I looked on the ground
where my feet were and it was a stack of
coins yeah and then Demetri said Tom do
it again cuz he he'd read he read our
book he read the book they did again
yeah and I kind of felt I kind of felt
all the hairs standing up on the back of
my neck and for a second I thought it
paltry guys was gonna come back and I
went now
it's not coming back it's not coming
back next society yeah you had kind of
telling that [ __ ] yeah and then and then
it just it just kind of came back for a
little while I did it did it did some
stuff after that it did some yeah it did
my things um if they wanted me to do it
again and I can't do it
it does it subconsciously I can't
control it that's what I mean I don't
think you basically all all it does now
well now it still turns the TV on every
now and then but the TV comes up I don't
on the back door while it was locked the
dead bolt was still in yeah can't saw
that one that was yeah you have to say
like our house it's like there's the
front door and like right across but
there's like a little four year for yay
whatever and then there's like double
doors that lead out to the back patio
now we never open those doors we don't
because we have a door to the back patio
in our bedroom we always use that one we
don't ever go through those doors
they're always locked and dead-bolted
and when one morning tom woke up and
went out it was like what was 8:30 9:00
you you got you went to work yeah up and
walked out right after you did maybe a
half hour yeah so like 8:30 problem yeah
and I walked out in the living room and
looked in the back doors were open just
one of them even though it's a double
door yeah one of the doors was open and
the deadbolt was still what still
thinking out no way that could happen
and the cat was sitting there just
looking at it like what she knew that
was wrong and she would normally go
outside but she wasn't outside she was
just sitting there staring at that door
you know that isn't right yeah cuz she
loves that door she asked us to open
that door because we never open it open
this door yeah she's like why you guys
never used this door yeah she likes to
go out of doors all time she loves doors
she's like portal Cady she likes she
likes to like go in and out she'll like
she'll go out one door and then she
wants to come back in but no I have to
come in district so that door was open
then the other night they you woke up
you hear the doorbell rang the doorbell
was ringing yeah and I checked it I said
oh you see him yes are you sure you
didn't dream that you would like no I
was wide awake yeah I want I walked out
well because I heard it rang like I woke
up because I you know when I worked
side of the home I usually would wake up
about four or five in the morning like
thinking it was time for me to get up I
don't know why I did that but so I think
it was if it was for 25 I remember
mm-hmm because I looked at my phone I'm
like why the [ __ ] did I wake up at 4 25
whatever I need to go back to sleep and
then I'm laying there and the doorbell
rang and I wigged out because who the
[ __ ] somebodies doorbell yeah I mean
the first thing I thought was oh my god
did somebody run over the cat dude I'm
like no she's inside it scared me he
woke me up out of it did well I wasn't
swayed to because at first I said I
heard it rang and I'm like oh [ __ ] and
then like I was really still and I sat
up and I listened and I didn't hear
anybody and then I said maybe I imagined
it like I know I didn't but I was like
maybe I imagined it but then it rang
again yeah and then I woke you up I was
like dude somebody's at the door and
then we like he gets his gun and he goes
out there and he's like and all his
other stuff and there was no one there
no and we live in a gated community yeah
a lot of security so there was no one
there no and then that was weird I was
kind of scared to look out that door to
go out there and then the other one that
happened recently doesn't that all
happened within a few weeks and another
thing that happened that that you forgot
is that you were putting on makeup and I
went to go change the DVD and as I walk
towards a DVD player the DVD door opened
up yeah the little tray open that just
opened up as I was walking toward like
it was good like it was yeah yeah put
some in here and then another thing
happened while I was playing a video
game you were at work I saw that
measuring cup that was up on the shelves
yeah fall through those two shelves and
hit the bottom and when it hit that
bottom shelf it landed on its basement
yeah I braided and it felt I saw it
happening out the corner of my eye
because I was looking at the screen but
I heard it hit and when I look turned
and looked I saw it come down like a
streak straight down I don't know how it
went straight down it would have had to
go through the wooden shell yes to go
down it went straight down and hit in
the center of the bottom shelf and it
hit me went and I could sat there and
watched it vibrate back and forth and
what was weird is when it first happened
it was like a wind blew through the
house and you know where I'm talking
about a wind never blows through there
but if I I sense a disturbance like a
wind blowing across that and it pushed
those shades in yeah when there was it
didn't scare me though it didn't scare
me I said man that was weird you know
did it again yeah didn't scare me that
time though yeah it doesn't scare me
anymore
well the doorbell scared me because it
was the middle of yeah I thought that
might have been a person that's what I
mean that's why I was scared like after
I was like oh well no one's there and
then the garage door opened up in the
middle yeah the garage started talking
yeah and that's it though that was all
recent stuff really the book focuses on
the stuff that happened back then yeah
and what happened recently how long ago
was that it was a few months ago months
ago okay that was that was that was
child's play compared to what it was
when I was 13 yeah oh yeah when I was 13
it was a lot better you would have loved
it I know I'm sorry I'm loved it was
awesome one of these it wasn't awesome
at the time yeah but looking back on it
I was I'm glad that that happened cuz
now I know there are certain things that
science can't explain yet I think there
is well I think they will there is some
they'll figure it out there are some
theories which we cover them in the book
but no so I mean we're kind of making
that clear you don't think it's a
supernatural I don't think it's
supernatural
no I think it's just a sonic physics
yeah having something to do with what
they call non-local consciousness yeah
Stuart Hameroff stuff yeah I'm kind of a
quantum soul theory yeah that's what he
called it and basically I mean we're
operating under the assumption that it's
you doing it but unconsciously
yeah it's not the conscious me it's the
it's the that's why it's so that's why
when I saw that remote control fly it
didn't scare me like it it startled me
well but I immediately turned to you and
said did you do that a ghost a ghost as
a spirit of the Dead
a poltergeist is the spirit of the
living yeah but it's not but if your
consciousness is not your spirit all
right your spirit
the Gnostics called it the daemon yeah
it's like the the super-ego
yeah the over you it's the
unconsciousness its its and your
unconscious is a lot more powerful than
your consciousness your unconscious is
actually in charge over your
consciousness yeah your consciousness is
not in charge of your consciousness so
some people might put it in a different
terminology you know if they were
Christian they might might want to call
it their guardian angel or you know or
maybe if you think it's the devil you
might call it say you know Satan demonic
possession you know but maybe you just
have a demonic soul I don't know but no
but I don't think it's something that
you could learn to control I don't think
so I don't I I don't feel like well I
feel like if somebody did you would know
about maybe ultra advanced aliens can or
something like that but I'll tell you
one thing based on what I saw when I was
a kid back in 13 back when I was 13 all
the things that it can do and all the
all the physics that it can violate if
you could figure out how to do it by
technological means you'd be
technologically superior yeah you'd be
able to bend the fabric of space-time
without using any and well because it
could teleport things yeah see that's
the thing
instant teleportation yeah the movement
of these objects you know would be
objects from downstairs appearing
upstairs without having gone through
stairwells and things like that so
either it's like instantaneous
instantaneous so it either penetrated
through solid matter or it just kind of
worm hold its way over and you can't
worm hole and you can't worm hole even a
tiny object without a whole bunch of
energy with using you know the physics
that we know today I don't think there
was any energy involved in this it may
be some kind of weird quantum when I say
quantum maybe even quantum physicists
don't know much about
a wide-open field at this point I mean
you know we don't know what kind of
weird [ __ ] it there's a way to cheat
let's just put it that way there's a way
to cheat and consciousness has something
to do with it yeah that's all I can say
about unless you woman answered question
do you want to write no we're actually
yeah we're actually uh over the hour
point yeah we probably should wrap this
actually went really fast you did if you
guys we talk about this a lot cuz you
know
yeah there's we've done a lot of other
podcasts a lot of other shows on on
mammoth mountain poltergeist if you guys
want to listen to those you know where
the road go did one end of days radio
we've been on a lot of shows yeah and I
mean actually if you go on my website
which is just Jenny Ashford comm there's
links there's a yeah there's a there's a
page called media appearances and it has
links to all the radio show some of them
are just me some of them are me and him
some of them are me and Steve Mehra
about talking about a couple of other
poltergeist cases but the audio book
mammoth mountain poltergeist is going to
be going probably be up by the time the
videos up probably I don't see why not
and if you don't feel like reading the
book you should listen to the audiobook
how long is it about three hours yeah
Jenny did a really good job on it oh
thank you mm-hmm
so I guess actually our bestseller in it
yeah well that in Rochdale and Rochdale
now Rochdale is that's like I said
that's that's a British case because
Steve Mayer is a British
parapsychologist so I did one with him
too now the audiobook of that is already
available but yeah many and you have a
copy haven't at least two more
poltergeist books coming soon yeah yeah
yeah so if you like the paranormal yeah
you know lots more stuff in store coming
from me other than the stuff that's
already up yeah I still want to do a
Bigfoot book can we do skunk ape instead
we can do the Florida Scott cable I
don't believe there is a Florida skunk
ape though you're the Florida skunk ape
yeah we already
it's true you guys the skunk ape exists
and he's sitting right here hands on
what I hate yeah all right anyway we're
gonna wrap this up so as I say at the
end of every episode if you liked our
show subscribe to our channel follow our
Twitter's 13 o'clock podcast and like
our Facebook page which is also called
13 o'clock podcast Annika oh my god that
was a Freudian slip 13 okay so hope you
liked the show
and we'll see you next week bye